Colson get back to base this is a level
seven that's right now we are at war
what do we do
one of the things you gotta love about
Joss Whedon is that he rarely lets a
detail go to waste my favorite example
is what you just saw from the first
Avengers movie when he uses the film
title card literally as an answer to a
question that's been posed by a
character on screen it's a great little
joke because it sets the tone for the
whole movie by drawing attention to the
film's packaging Whedon is letting us
know that he knows that this is just a
movie that it's not going to take itself
too seriously and that there are going
to be jokes that man is playing Galaga
he does a similar thing at the end of
Avengers 2 using a creative cut that
literally plants a word in your head
Avengers hopefully we're all thinking of
the same word now maybe it's a small
thing but the way art is packaged has
always fascinated me because packaging
like this is just another thing that the
artists has to choose it ought to be a
creative decision like all the creative
decisions that went into the work itself
of course when you're dealing with big
properties and millions of dollars
artists don't always or even usually get
to choose what a film or a book title is
going to be the book cover or the movie
poster is often designed with commercial
incentives in mind but that's not the
case for all art forms or even all forms
of packaging we didn't obviously had to
name his film The Avengers but he found
an interesting way to work that title
into the film similarly in the 2006
James Bond movie Casino Royale director
Martin Campbell and the Bond team we're
looking to reboot the franchise propos'd
Austin Powers post can't be era to make
it more gritty and in line with the best
action films of the time obviously they
had to include the iconic gun barrel
sequence but by forgoing the normal dot
dot dot gun barrel instead working it
into the story they broadcast the
message that this bond is a different
beast altogether my interest in this
kind of packaging I think Springs from
epigraphs those quotes you see at the
beginning of books I use it gross to
signal that the reader should look in a
certain direction while reading that
they should keep certain things in mind
paths that's a favorite writer of mine M
John Harrison who I think hits the point
exactly epigraphs and need all the
trappings that exist in and around a
work of art or in some way a part of it
their instructions or simply suggestions
on how to receive the project in
question this is a good example from
Tarantino's grindhouse feature death
Proof which couches the story in the
look and feel of the exploitation genre
movies of the 1970s all the way down to
the grainy film stock and the fake
trailers for similarly styled B movies
after these kinds of touches though not
directly part of the film itself paint
the immediate space around the movie
with a kind of aura that sets the mood
of course there are plenty of examples
of beautiful title sequences going back
through the history of film the king of
them all is Saul Bass the designer
behind everything from psycho and
vertigo to Goodfellas and Casino here's
how bass use his job I have felt for
some time that the audience involvement
with the film should really begin with a
very first frame there seemed to be a
real opportunity to use titles in a new
way to actually create a climate for the
story that was about to unfold vasas
philosophy of establishing the film's
climate lives on even if extended title
sequences are becoming a little less
common actually I've been noticing a lot
of these title sequences moving to the
end of films the closing credits of Blue
Valentine for example features
quick-fire work glimpses of the
relationship that just ended with the
film
I remember watching these credits in the
theater and being completely transfixed
as they send your mind back across the
story making the heartbreak of the
ending even more poignant and on the
complete other side of the spectrum the
closing credits sequence of 22 Jump
Street is a brilliant send up of
Hollywood's franchise mentality of
endless sequels as maybe the first time
I've ever seen a credit sequence that is
even funnier than an already hilarious
movie
one of the examples I love most is the
title sequence from Francois Truffaut's
adaptation of Fahrenheit 451 a story
about a society that doesn't allow its
citizens to read books so to banish
words from the viewers mind Truffaut has
the opening titles read aloud instead
from a novel by Ray Bradbury music by
Bernard Herrmann director a photographer
Nicolas Roeg not every film or every
piece of art needs to pay so much
attention to the packaging that
surrounds it but I love something like
this because it actually adds to the
story the same could be said for the
title sequence of the wire which
entwines fragments of all the narrative
perspectives of the show and even some
footage from the episodes themselves and
puts them on an equal footing
reinforcing creator David Simon's Maxim
that the wire is not about Jim McNulty
or Avon Barksdale or crime or punishment
or drugs or violence it's about the city
these titles I think do a little more
than echo the themes they help to
develop it all artists are trying in
some way to get their intentions across
to an audience even if that intention is
to make the packaging around their work
as minimal as possible
a number of painters don't title their
canvases for example or simply name them
with a number the idea here is to take
the work on its own terms
movies and books don't have that option
but when Woody Allen uses the same font
and title sequence for every single
movie he's ever done the point I think
is to look beyond the titles to the film
itself but even that non-decision
is a kind of decision I mean the title
isn't the most important thing about a
movie but attention to detail is
something that I appreciate as a film
goer I mean if you're going to spend all
that time and all that money making a
feature film why not try to make
everything in and around it meaningful
forget it I can't go in two minutes out
I'm sorry I can't do it
blown it already I you know I can't go
in in the middle in the middle we're
only miss the titles are in Swedish
[Music]
there is a nerd writer video every
Wednesday so if you click that box right
there you'll subscribe to this channel
and get all the videos ah my girlfriend
just just scare the [ __ ] out of me I
have to thank Squarespace for sponsoring
this video they make sleek intuitive
websites I just made one called the
nerdwriter dotnet you can check that out
and if you sign up for a year you get a
free domain name and if you use the
offer code nerdwriter you can get 10%
off your first purchase also me and my
girlfriend are going to be living in
Venice Italy for the next month starting
Friday so if you live out there if you
want to get in touch you can email me at
the red or dot at gmail and I will see
you guys next Wednesday the rest of you
hopefully I see some of you in Venice